the bill for one public commode has
taxpayers ready to unload
that's pretty good even though the whole
city is a public toilet the city of San
Francisco is building one public toilet
that could cost up to 1.7 million bucks
and it won't be completed till
2025. 1.7 million bucks that's nearly as
much as Nancy Pelosi spent on her face
and you wouldn't sit on that either
because it's painful for everybody
disgusting wrote that the bathroom is
just 150 square feet of space in one
Town Square local officials were set to
celebrate the plans but the event was
canceled after the San Francisco
Chronicle exposed the Absurd cost also a
local vagrant used these scissors for
the ribbon cutting to stab someone in
the eye
could have been true a spokesman blamed
the insane price tag on skyrocketing
construction costs along with the
processes that include planning drawing
permits reviews and public Outreach but
geez it's just a toilet they're not like
it's not like they're trying to build a
walk-in bathtub for Michael Moore now
thank you
too soon
He's Alive Now
now compare this to a state that
actually gets stuff done less than three
weeks after Hurricane Ian destroyed the
Sanibel Causeway at Southwest Florida it
reopened those results came faster than
the flash when he hooked up with
Superman
it only took a few thousand loads of
dirt Rock asphalt 36 000 man hours but
it's good to go
sorry and so is the Pine Island Bridge
in Fort Myers repaired in just a few
days and so far no one's taken a dump on
it
thanks cat
so it's no wonder people are leaving
Progressive run cities for places like
Florida but I do wonder what San
franciscans will do while they wait for
their million dollar toilet to be
finished we asked to one local for
comment
so is one of San Francisco's most famous
public defecators what are your thoughts
about the public bathroom not being
ready till 2025. oh hey man what's the
rush you know God already gave us a
bathroom you don't have to flush and
it's called the ground wow so what are
your plans until then oh well I'm an
artist you know and this city is my
canvas I mean think Jackson Pollock but
Brown wow this sounds very ambitious no
and you guys got to sign up for my new
social media platform it's called talk
it's just like Tick Tock but you film
yourself outside preferably in a famous
place our motto is think globally
locally okay oh God what did I just step
in sorry that's mine
ah you know
here's
this is literally the definition of
government waste
I see when I when I heard there'd been
this extraordinary expense on a 1.7
million dollar toilet and I thought I
wonder Gutfeld the late night King now
his Palace is this the first stage of
the expansion because last time I was on
this show there was no audience I mean
this guy's getting huge yes I just
assumed yeah
yeah
yeah so is I assumed it was one of your
new you know little Cruise once that
you've acquired as the new king of late
night but when I found out this was
serious you think I want uh I saw the
pictures how on Earth can you spend yeah
that amount of money on a what looked
like a little shed yeah uh so I don't
know how they Justified it but then I
read about more of the details and it
seemed like every step of the way of all
the planning permissions and all the
authority trying to get it that was
where all the money was going and it was
a really interesting insight into the
ridiculous waste of these authorities
right you just look at it and go that
should have cost two hundred thousand
dollars maximum the fact is cost another
one and a half million is because you
lot are wasting public money on a
grotesque scale and they're all paying
each other off yeah I saw I read that
too and it was like there's the
architect and then Community feedback
and then quote conduct a multi-phase
review for one toilet yeah
how what does that process look like
what are you reviewing exactly I think
there's like one thing you have to
review yeah
and you know in the moment it gets
installed somebody's just gonna pee all
over the uh the seat yes and then
nobody's going to want to use it except
junkies and hookers
which isn't a bad way to use a toilet
did you have more to say no I mean I'm
glad that San Francisco is not just
giving up on toilets
to my great Theory Tyrus
what if this is actually San Francisco's
new tourist attraction because doesn't
San Francisco if you're going to think
of a tourist attraction the most
expensive toilet is San Francisco forget
the Golden Gate Bridge you can't poop
there
so everyone come see the toilet that
nobody uses yes yes because everyone
just goes around while they wait in line
to see it no this is unfortunately this
is California this is California this I
grew up there this is what they do they
we we're not allowed to call liberals
corrupt but this is corruption at its
finest everything in California is
outrageous they want to build a Subway
and a train It was one like 25 billion
dollars Japan built an entire one for a
fraction of that why because they have
to pay all the little Rich buddies in
their little committees and they're
planning things because cat what they
were going to do is they were going to
literally have 20 people stand around
the toilet one person flush it and go
here's my bill I know and then each
person watching the water go down making
sure it's clockwise not counterclockwise
uh we'll probably get around 200 000
each and research fees that's the
problem with California they in
everything when I was a kid the LA Zoo
was under construction it still is yes
and that train that you mentioned
they're going to just scrap they're
Scrappy like 100 billion dollars
something crazy well you know because
they got paid yeah they had no intention
of doing it they're going to build one
toilet you literally go to Home Depot
and get one for 50 bucks yes you know
what I'm saying and you can put a tent
around it and you know what I'm saying
that's it yeah that's and you gotta talk
yeah that's the problem with government
in general no it's not it's the people
in it and that's the problem we have to
get these Crooks out and they need to
start disclosing how much money they're
making because you take a job that pays
a hundred thousand dollars a year but
you're a millionaire before your first
before your first year of taxes come in
there's a problem yeah you Lara you know
you you live in Florida now it's a it's
such a contrast where you see this
damaged infrastructure from this
hurricane it's just being rebuilt faster
we're like little like down there
they're like little ants rebuilding
stuff you know ants rebuild things I
think and we have a lot of great toilets
down there too so that's the great news
and they didn't cost 1.7 million dollars
I think the good news about the one in
San Francisco is there's probably a week
week and a half that people actually be
able to use it before it's like syringe
written with you know the standard
toilet situation in San Francisco but
you're right it's the reason so many
people wanted to move to States like
Florida because you can actually
accomplish things and get things done if
people are willing to do it if they if
you don't have corruption Tyrus you know
it's a beautiful thing to see happen so
very happy there and it's not like San
Francisco is flush with cash
wow yes I did it they're gonna steal it
you know that right the first week it's
open it's going to get stolen yes
I'm gonna steal that seat all right
up next leftist Talking Heads rip Trump
supporters to shred hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else